boom this deadly sleeper virus triggers
Alzheimer's do-it-yourself cure for
cancer dissolves deadly tumors in this
little as 48 hours are you literally
feeding cancer cells by putting this one
food on your dinner plate you ask me how
bad could it be
here it is hello welcome to gummies a
lot today we're talking about that
senior scams that are going on around I
said this is something I haven't focused
on so much in my in my channel but
honestly it's gotten so bad that we're
gonna talk about it I've got my screen
put up right here basically I saw this
the other day
seniors lose more than 27 billion
dollars to elder a fraud every year
obviously we have people talking about
some of these scams we have like
telemarketer scams are very common to be
goofed on on the Internet
Microsoft warning you didn't know - no
you should know by now do you not
understand that you've just invested
almost two hours of your time trying to
scam someone but the stuff that I've
kind of been surprised hasn't been
covered our health scams they haven't
been that widely covered and given their
kind of everywhere it's surprising to
see that so today we're going to talk
about it we're gonna talk about them for
your yeah your Mamaw or whoever so get
them in you to bring you send your
seniors this this video you get them in
this video because I want to talk to
them I want to talk to your man my your
grandpa your pop-pop you ppalli or
whatever whatever you call them let's
talk because they're sending they're
getting sent emails that try to scam it
now the reason you probably at home you
youth you whippersnappers haven't heard
of this and I hadn't heard of it up
until very recently is because these
scams do a very good job of staying off
this searchable Internet and I mean that
literally the only way you can find a
lot of these things is they come through
email so you have to find your way onto
this email
they have these like health newsletter
email lists and then once they know
you're the kind of person who's looking
for alternative health cures they go and
they unload the crap you know and try to
get you into all this to try to
basically milk you for all that you're
worth so you're saying to yourself
Steven how bad can it really be okay
let's just let's jump into this boom are
you literally feeding cancer cells by
putting this bun food on your dinner
plate you asked me I'm kind of gonna be
there it is look at this can a late
stage cancer really be cured with
absolutely no radiation no chemotherapy
no surgery not even a pill vitamin or
natural supplement and is that cure as
actually as easy as inexpensive as
swapping one kind of food for another
let me repeat that could cancer even in
stage terminal cancer just be completely
wiped out by just eating one food
friends I'm happy to say the answer is
yes so this is like a 27 this is just
one example some 27 page long thing to
get you to get by this guy's book now
it's not simple there's twists and turns
there's it's a long story to get you
emotionally invested in this but
basically this is snake oil I mean of
course it's snake oil because the guy's
saying that Oh food swap can cure any
kind of cancer oh my gosh that is Joe's
hilarious can late-stage cancer really
be cured with absolutely no radiation no
chemotherapy no surgery not even a
single pill vitamin or ventral
supplement friends I'm happy to say the
answer is yes get okay
this totally preys on people who have a
curable diseases and then you basically
sell them a product I know I know a lot
of you are thinking nobody would ever
fall for this people fall for this all
the time and I think honestly if you put
yourself in you know their shoes you
could probably see how it happens say
your grandma Matilda
okay put yourself in her shoes she's got
a curable cancer she's got every problem
in the book some snake oil salesman
sends her an email saying that it's all
curable and gives her this incredible
story well I mean
you know they believe it this is a
billion-dollar industry this scam right
here this kind of scam this is a
billion-dollar industry
and it's not illegal amazingly it's not
illegal which is why I'm warning you
guys about it because unlike a lot of
other scams which are illegal they can
personating people this is technically
not illegal amazingly go USA USA number
one because basically they skirt the
lines of what's legal to say and what's
not legal to say and it's definitely
riding that line of complete false
advertising but there's just no
regulation over this industry there's
none so this is fine to say look at this
this here's another way you know that
this is getting your pee pop the last
time ducks your meanwhile this is your
Pete pop this inexpensive natural
treatment is believed to have saved
Ronald Reagan's life but when buried for
more than thirty years
oh how convenient now thanks to this
amazing thing that you can only get for
like however much this is it was $50
$100 she knows only this thing will tell
you the secret cure Do It Yourself cure
for cancer dissolves deadly tumors in
this little list 48 hours just see stuff
like as little as 48 hours if you ever
took them to court for this they would
say well we said as little as 48 hours
we didn't say it wouldn't dissolve in 48
hours we just said it could so that's
how they get around this stuff it's just
a bunch of work play but basically
there's stealing your seniors money so I
just wanted to make you guys aware of it
and it all it all kind of follows the
same formula okay because they know the
demographic the order demographic so let
me tell you the formula so they they
started up with like a shocking thing so
the so on a common pitches this cure was
hidden hidden from America from seniors
and it saved some famous person's life
like Ronald Reagan right or let's go to
this one look at this look at this look
at this let's just jump around here in
1944 a German scientist performing
cancer research for Hitler made an
amazing discovery did the Nazis bear a
cure true cure for cancer I did not see
that coming
basically all these things have followed
the same formula so again same formula
even though it's just kind of so again
same formula you know you try to hook
the reader with some crazy claim about
some famous person being related to some
cure or something like that
it's an incredible cure that was
discovered but loss of this found a
priceless war relic covered up by our US
government for 70 years so that hooks
you win and then they introduced like a
sob story about some hidden doctor who
would never listened to Yeti areata and
they have uncovered a none of it none of
the mainstream establishment wants to to
cover this and interestingly they will
never insult your doctor because these
people are professionals in psychology
and they know that you while you
distrust the institution of
pharmaceuticals and the institution of
you know medicine you don't dislike your
family doctor so they'll always be kind
about your family doctor and they'll
always bash the pharmaceutical injury
industry that's a kind of a funny quirk
of like their sales letters and they
just load you up with all these
buzzwords that make you think your
cancers terrible and it's gonna about to
be cured look at this what a busy area
just have to scroll down and we'll find
we'll find it arrays cancerous tumors
like they never existed in the first
place restoring your perfect health
again
assert and yes while young people might
be able to see right through this stuff
and see it for the snake love it it is
old people they don't have a choice to
see through it because they're faced
with terminal illnesses and if it's
between dying or trying out some new
alternative medicine that may work may
not work they're gonna try out the
Eternity medicine they have no choice
and so they end up buying these
ridiculous scams let's keep going
through them Nobel Prize winning chemist
unlocks universal vaccine for cancer
diabetes heart disease and Alzheimer's
survival rates or 2,000 percent as
tumors vanish blood sugar plunges
arteries clear and lost memories or
restores yeah so this is the kind of
stuff that it's gonna they want to get
there
your grandparents pants basically get
their wallets open them up take their
money and get out and I'm just shocked
no one else is talking about this I mean
for all the people that talk about you
know phone call scam stuff like this
I've never heard of this industry until
basically I got sent some of these
letters by people who were starting to
become aware of ok fake guru that's kind
of the financial side of things
it's more like targeted young people
there's also this thing going on with
seniors and I was like I had never heard
of this these kind of like basically
email scams and they're making millions
millions of dollars there's this famous
company Agora
it may be the most famous example of
this who there's several publishing
companies that basically all they do is
pump out newsletters some of them are
financial some of them are
health-related like for example the Nazi
one that was done by health sense media
which is like an arm of their little
thing going on and that's all they do
and they have sold wait for it billions
of dollars of publications like this let
me say that again because their hurts
might have to say okay stuff just like
this Agora has sold stuff just like this
just like the Nazis bury cancer cure
they've sold a billion dollars worth of
these newsletters the people like your
papaw your mama your Mimi your meemaw
everybody and it's got to stop guys it's
got to stop in the meantime tell the
seniors you know that this stuff is
happening they're getting robbed I think
this stuff is real because they gets fed
some sob story about some super doctor
they've never heard of and if you just
buy this a little book you're gonna be
saved all this stuff and when you
actually get the book it's just stuff
you could have googled online like dr.
otto warburg which is there well who
they're talking about in this Nazi
Health pamphlet is a German scientist
that like you can just Wikipedia you
just
Wikipedia all this stuff and instead
they just sell it to your your parents
your grandparents for money to prey on
the elderly and those with problems so
yeah this is something I just have been
wanting to talk about for a while and I
I just wanted to kind of get it in one
video well let's go through let's take
down a few more while we're at it this
deadly sleeper virus triggers
Alzheimer's if you were born before 1967
there's a 90% chance you have it okay so
who are they targeting obviously who are
they targeting that line right there
tells you here they're targeting seniors
right because if you're born before 1967
too late oh gosh I have it I've got to
read this thing here's how to deactivate
the virus that's that is stealing your
memories and reverse the damage that's
already been done I don't know what to
tell you guys preying on people with
Alzheimer's is maybe the lowest thing
you can do you might as well be
slithering on the ground eating dirt
because that's how low that is think
about it
think about making money by basically
tricking people assault with Alzheimer's
okay
tricking them so that's what this is
nice dr. Rothfeld who's that nobody
knows
great just you no more crap I mean I
don't know if I have to tell you guys
this but you can't reverse Alzheimer's
it's really disgusting but um yeah I'm
just making this video to tell you guys
that this thing exists like I never had
heard of this I had I didn't know how
big of a problem this was I didn't know
the scope of this thing I mean people
are making millions of dollars billions
of dollars literally off of your
grandparents AARP off their retirement
off their Social Security it's
disgusting
be safe out there don't give anybody
your money Pharma sucks but alternative
health people suck more
[Music]
[Music]